[Music]
how famous you all know how many people
that we're highlighting a long time
problem of racial profiling and unjust
violence against blacks in our country
[Music]
the earliest memory I remember getting
called Anwar was in high school I was in
middle school I was called the n-word in
general in middle school I'll never
forget it I liked it I believe every
detail give you a synopsis I wouldn't
necessarily say the n-word but I've
definitely been in a situation where
it's very racial you know fans would be
fans like any sport they don't see you
as people can you walk on that court for
whatever reason they say whatever they
want
I've been to games in my high school
career people have showed up in like my
jersey with like a gorilla outfit on I
remember my freshman year my brother was
a singing we have like a lot of black
kids with dreads and one kid doctor and
they and the fans of it who's the monkey
and they started doing that out he's
like wow this is crazy
I was an artist at one time and a middle
school kid coming and where we were just
walking out from gym class literally it
was kind of weird how why even calling
me it but he pushed me and just called
me the n-word I was like oh I just turn
around stuck him right in the jaw I
remember I was in a Lee a game ball just
tipped out of my hands and it goes out
of balance and the kids had to sell the
call like it was gonna be their ball
even though he knew like he hit it out
of bounds
he was like I'm locking that up and then
he called me the n-word and I was like
what'd you just say bro it's being said
by white person it's definitely a
derogatory towards you and part of you
was like I thought that was over
you know I thought we were beyond that
but at the same time you know you see it
you know full circle right there it's
not about anywhere no unfortunately I
was her private school so it was all
about 10% of the school was black maybe
and I wanted to go to a friend's house
but she kind was just like you know she
come to my house you have to sleep
outside and I'm like I think that's when
it kind of clicked with me like people
might not just like you doesn't color
your skin to compare an african-american
to a monkey I think that's disrespectful
but and that's just like the problem
with society there's some people who
were raised in racist environments and
it's a part of who they are because of
the influence that they had on their
life said you heard me and said it again
like looked at me dead in the eyes and
his goal was that and I didn't even
realized was to make me upset but that
was the first time that somebody light
looked me in my eyes and like yeah this
is what it is I think just the dialogue
is important a lot of times people are
afraid to have those discussions awkward
conversations so being able to talk
about things and discuss things I think
that gives everybody a better
perspective because I don't know how you
grew up someone else who may not look
like us come like to come from places
like us may not understand what it's
like to go through some things that we
go through doing your homework creates a
better environment and knowing your
history creates a better environment
there but no matter if you're black
white Chinese Mexican no matter what you
are I think it's very very important
that people are not black that kind of
stated take a stance and say you know
I'm with them the media the viral not a
type stuff is cool you know I mean but
it's not really affect that no changes
just putting more money and media
companies pockets like if they keep
talking about sudden it actually matters
maybe we start to see a different
culture coming up we're fighting for a
lot of different causes now and before
it seemed like you know
no you can't do that you can't do that
that's wrong and that's wrong and that's
just says a lot of times and you don't
have a discussion you don't it's just up
for interpretation and I think that's
when it becomes a problem it seems that
we're open as a society to to change to
you know standing up for those who can't
and I think we should just respect each
other a little bit more even if you
disagree with something still so that
personal whisper having that dialogue is
important that way you're able to kind
of express yourself air things out that
you like things that you don't like and
then you can kind of get on the same
page with athletes like myself and
others we just gotta continue to use our
voice and express who we are and just
know that it's bigger than the sport
that we play
[Music]